regardez mais pour l'instant les rêves
de chacun bon les chéris êtes content ça
se passe bien je devrais bien bon je
vous ai réunis aujourd'hui c'est parce
que bien entendu vous allez vous amuser
et puis on ira à la recherche du père
noël
et peut-être que tout le monde
rencontrera le père noël ce qui est pas
sûr faut que je vois avec lui parce que
je chante contacteur assez directe avec
lui ou parle beaucoup c'est le conte se
parle beaucoup
ou bien peut-être qui redonnera certains
d'entre vous qui verront le père noël
avant de le voir le père noël je peux
lui faire passer tous veut donc vous
allez lire ce que vous voulez et je vais
essayer de voir avec le père noël
si on peut exaucer vos vous d'accord
benjamin castaldi qu'est ce que tu
aimerais donc j'aimerais bien avoir un
corps de rêve c'est vrai débat déjà vous
êtes bien parti merci mais vous aimeriez
avoir un corps brûlés entendu le monde
et peut-être accord pour avoir peut-être
ensuite une nouvelle femme encore une
fois et vous re marié prouille 18e fois
je cours je vous laisse l'entière
responsable mardi maxime guennoun avec
siri qui souhaiteraient rencontrer la
mère noël sous depuis deux semaines je
vous montre l'aspect de mon côté
célibataire endurci mais les choses
changent
et oui une mère noël pour vous une vraie
mère noël et bah écoutez je vais voir ce
que je peux faire je vais demander au
père noël
je ne dis pas que tous les voeux vont
être exaucés tient tout cas sachez le il
vous aime bien vous êtes bien il va
faire le nécessaire
si oui quelque chose de matériel après
un service à raclette ça me va aussi
d'accord merci
c'est bien on le retrouve matthieu
delormeau bat déjà exaucé le voeu du
père noël parce qu'il paraît qu'ils
devraient faire à ces leviers avec moi
donc ça déjà s'est mis d'accord on va
voir peut-être un peu démunis et ensuite
mon souhait à moi et j'espère vous
comprendrez s'est retrouvé aussi une vie
un petit peu normal et avoir la chance
comme vous de ne pas être connue partout
où je vais pour peut-être juste en
france mais dans les autres pays comme
vous l'avez constaté à l'arrivée les
reports dans les autres pays peut-être
être comme vous noan anonyme
vous souhaiteriez retrouver l'anonymat
ouais je pense que j'ai pas de besoin
demandez pas mal je vais me demander à
moi même ce n'est pas mon avis ça je
pense que ça va être pour le film voit
la mer à vous jean michel moi je sais
être raisonnable j'aurai une trottinette
électrique avec des grosses gros c'est
vrai pour ce que les gens sachent ce que
je vois là je vais être plus écologique
mais marre de prendre ma voiture
pourrait venir simplement travailler
j'habite pas loin à l'école michel mr on
y va avec des grosses roues écoutez
peut-être que vous aurez les deux je
vais vous dire mais c'est vrai on peut
être hostile est avec une nouvelle ma
faim isabelle morini-bosc il voudrait
absolument rencontrer un rennes rennes
d'accord très bien mais bon on va voir
mon avis votre but peut être exaucées
avait aussi sa valeur sans chimie la
ring pour s'agit le beau bébé
alors moi honnêtement je veux rien pour
moi j'aimerais que le père noël soit
j'ai dit ouais avec fatou parce qu'elles
le méritent
comme toujours exactement de beaux
cadeaux pour fatou alors moi un beau
cadeau comme j'aime beaucoup les
personnes âgées ce serait de dormir avec
le père noël une vie une seule donnée et
a mis en lumière avec moi
dormir avec le père de dormir avec le
vern on va voir ce qu'on peut faire en
plus une patte familial jacques bernois
bravo bravo aujourd'hui c'est peut-être
la première que t'es fait dans la nuit
qu'elle iv novellis alors moi ce que
j'aimerais c'est me marier dans l'année
2010 9,1
bah oui au revoir oui bah ça peut être
2018 mais très vite et j'aimerais aussi
que max fasse l'amour le plus vite
possible aaa
bah je souhaite être un complément non
mais s'y attendait on sait jamais bah
moi vu que j'adore la période de noël
mon plus grand rêve c'était de partir un
laponie et grâce à vous le match est en
train de le réaliser
si tu dois régler à deuxième et partage
d'un chamakh quelqu'un de ne surtout pas
dormir avec toi de moi j'ai demandé au
père noël de pouvoir passer un petit
moment avec toi en paix tu as fait pour
ma part c'est bon ça je te fais toute
ambition d'ailleurs ça je vais faire le
maximum pour le père c'est que t'as pas
un fléau
je vais voir tout ça et je vous le dis
certains d'entre vous rencontreront le
père noël bon les chéris amusez vous et
lâchez moi
[Applaudissements]